hello everyone my name is lennox waters
and this stock is called my other car is
your car and it's about compromising the
tesla model x kilos entry system
now in a modern day vehicle like the
tesla model x you usually have two ways
of entering or opening the vehicle
the first method is remote killer
sanding so you press a button on the key
fob the key fob generates a holding code
or hopping code
the car verifies this code and then
unlocks the doors
massive entry is if you have the key fob
in your pocket
you approach the car the car sends a
challenge to the key fob the key fob
computes the cryptographic response
sends it back to the vehicle and then
the vehicle verifies the response
so the second scenario is used to
passively open the car but also to start
the car
now if we take one of these key fobs and
open it up then we find the following
printed circuit board inside of it
you can see it's quite complicated and
has quite a few components so let's look
at all of them individually
so the first thing we see is a texas
instruments
cc2541 it's a bluetooth low energy
microcontroller
this microcontroller is packed with a
bluetooth low energy range extender
and then at the other side of the pcb we
have a maximum integrated
low low frequency transponder chip
so this transponder chip allows the
keyfob to receive signals on a 22
kilohertz frequency
then on the left of the pcb we have an
accelerometer which is likely being used
to try and prevent relay attacks
or to try and increase the battery life
of the key fob and finally we have an
infineon slm-97
common criteria certified secure element
so this secure element underwent
certification by common criteria which
means that the secure element has been
certified to be
secure against certain attacks
now as you can imagine the secure
element will be quite difficult for us
to attack
but as it turns out in the way the
system is designed we actually only have
to attack the bluetooth energy chip
because once we compromise this chip we
can send arbitrary commands to the
secure element
now to figure out how all of these
components communicate with each other i
built a small breakout board basically
that allows me to
connect the logic analyzer and see all
of the communication between the
different chips
so you could even use this keyfob to
actually open or unlock a car if the key
fob is paired to it and then see
basically by connecting a logic analyzer
what all of the communication between
these chips is
and in doing so we can then learn how
the device works
and then we can make a more detailed
view of the first image we had
so basically in a remote keyless entry
scenario a user will first press a
button
this button press is handled by the
bluetooth energy microcontroller
that set then sends a request token
command to the secure element
the secure element computes a
cryptographic token that is sent back to
the microcontroller
and then it is transmitted over
bluetooth low energy as a
broadcast packet to the car the car
verifies the token and then unlocks
in the passive kills entry scenario the
car will first stand the challenge
over low frequency
to this maximum integrated transponder
chip
that takes the challenge and sends it to
the microcontroller over spi
the microcontroller then again sends it
to the secure element the secure element
performs some cryptographic operations
computes response
and then the bluetooth low energy
microcontroller sends it back to the car
now here it's important to note that the
only way to compute a valid response or
a valid token and just to unlock the car
is to have the key that is stored in the
secure element
and getting that key out will be quite
difficult
but what's interesting here compared to
other kilos entry systems is that we
have this bluetooth low energy
microcontroller
and with having this microcontroller and
bluetooth low energy there is more
attack surface
as it turns out if you take the battery
out of this keyfob and then put it back
in
or basically power cycle the keyfob then
it will start advertising itself as a
connectable loot low energy peripheral
and so you can connect to it with an app
on your phone for example and then you
can see all of the services and
characteristics that are exposed on the
device
so there's two of these services that
are interesting for us
the first one being overlapped download
and that basically allows us to update
the firmware on the keyfob wirelessly
over bluetooth
secondly there is an apdu interface
apd stands for application protocol data
unit and those of you familiar with
smart cards and secure elements know
that these are basically commands that
you can send to the secure elements
so presumably to this service we can
send commands to the secure element
now let's
first take a look at how you communicate
with a secure element
and in this case actually the secure
element interface is quite similar to
that of a smart card so you may
recognize this pin out which is an
example from a chip for example
the kind that you would find in your
banking card
and this chip is a secure element in the
keyfob and it basically has the same
sort of interface just in a different
package
so what we did here is we basically
built a pcb took a secure element from
the key fob put it on the pcb and then
this pcb we can put in a smart card
reader and then basically communicate
with the secure element from python
now to send commands or apdu commands to
the secure elements these commands
usually exist for out of at least five
bytes so we first have the command class
byte which basically indicates if this
is a
proprietary or standard command
then we have the command byte itself
the next two parameter bytes and then
finally is a byte that indicates the
number of additional input bytes for
this command
so for example if you press a button on
the keyfob
then what will happen is the
microcontroller will send this apdu
command
to the secure element and as you can see
this
command indicates that there's three
additional input bytes
the secure element confirms that we can
send these input bytes and then we send
these three input bytes
now these input bytes in this case
indicate the kind of action we want to
perform so do we want to unlock the
doors do we want to lock them maybe you
want to unlock the falcon wind doors and
so on
after receiving these three bytes the
secure element will compute the
cryptographic response and then
indicates to us that it is ready
we can then read the response back which
is 16 bytes and then the secure element
also indicates that everything was
successful
now if we go back to the bluetooth
energy microcontroller and this bootload
energy to apu interface
then it is clear that basically this
interface can be used to send these
sorts of apd commands to the secure
element over bluetooth
and this functionality is normally used
during pairing
and of course the engineers at tesla
realize that this can be a security
issue
so certain commands such as the the get
unlocked token that we discussed earlier
are blocked from being used to this
bluetooth low energy interface
otherwise you could simply ask the key
fob for an unlocked token and then
unlock the car
then the second interface that we
discussed earlier is the overact
download service
and over act download is basically texas
instruments
implementation of over the air software
updates and it basically allows you to
update the firmware on the
cc2541 microcontroller
now the example implementation provided
by texas instruments actually contained
a few vulnerabilities
so
one of our students at the university
actually looked at this example
implementation and identified two major
issues so the first one being that they
use aes in counting modes to encrypt the
firmware
but they had a book that basically
resulted in the country being reset
after for aes blocks and you can see the
results here on the bottom of the slide
so on the left you can see basically the
plain text firmware image and then on
the right you can see the encrypted
firmware image and you can clearly see
here at the bottom that has
too much structure for this to be
properly encrypted
and as a result
you can actually decrypt this firmware
image without knowledge of the key
and the second book was that they used
cbc mac to provide authentication of the
firmware image but they used the
non-constant time implementation of
memcompair so this implementation would
also be vulnerable to a timing attack
now tesla didn't actually use any of
these security features provided in the
example implementation by ti
but they decided to use rsa signatures
to
verify the authenticity of the firmware
and this signature would then be
verified by the secure elements this is
of course a good choice
but as it turns out the result provided
by the secure element was simply being
ignored
so the
microcontroller would ask the secure
element is this a valid firmware image
secure element would say no this
firmware image is not valid and then
the microcontroller would still accept
the firmware
we are not sure how this issue ended up
in the production build of the
of the model x keyfob firmware but we
believe that maybe it has been it was a
leftover from development
so now what we want to do is we want to
build a malicious firmware image
that allows us to send arbitrary apdu
commands to the secure element inside of
the keyfob
so what we can do is we can build a
custom framework
and this would require us to become
familiar with the ti tooling and
software development kit
which would require some time and would
likely end up with a firmware image that
doesn't have all the functionality that
the original keyframe has
we could also take the original firmware
and then statically reverse engineer it
try to find the block list and then
basically patch the firmware
however for this specific platform there
isn't any
good support for example github supports
the 8051 instruction set but not the
custom additions that were done to this
platform
so in the end what we decided to do was
basically brute force the firmware
modification process
because this could be easily automated
and then we could just leave it run for
a few hours
not have to do any of these tedious
tasks
so the idea is really quite simple we
assume that a block list is implemented
using if statements or a case
and that this will likely be compiled to
conditional instructions such as jump if
not 0 or jump with zero
so then the idea is to basically replace
an occurrence of the jump if not zero
instruction with a jump if zero
instruction then we flash this modified
firmware image to the key fob
we connect over bluetooth and we try to
send
the
request unlock token apu command
if we receive a response then we know
that our command was successful and that
we successfully patched the firmware
if not then we simply
continue the loop uh patch the next
instruction and try again
and eventually in a few hours of time
you have a modified thermal image that
no longer has a block list
so now our plan of attack currently
looks something like this we take the
key fob we take out the battery put it
back in
we then connect to the keyfob and push
our own malicious firmware image and
this then allows us to send arbitrary
arbitrary apu commands to the secure
element
we can request a valid rolling code to
this apu interface and then use that
rolling code to unlock the car
now i think we all agree that step one
in this plan of attack is not really
that nice or cool because we would have
to have physical access to the key fob
so let's see if we can get rid of step
one
and to do this we will look at the body
control module
so this is one of the ecu's that is
located inside of the model x
and i know that some of the more
interesting regions here um
so most importantly for us is that
there's the the same secure element as
in the key fob is also in the body
control module
and then we have this main processor
which is a three scale spc spc-56 series
that can communicate with other ecu's in
the car to these i o and bus interfaces
it can also send
low frequency commands to the key fob
using these lf transceiver ics and then
this also of course antennas connected
to these connectors
and then of course this pcm also needs
to be able to communicate over bluetooth
low energy
now what you figured out is that this
body control module can actually send a
wake up command over low frequency to
the keyboard
and basically this allows
a car to wake up key fobs that have been
paired to it
and the low frequency command
basically contains an identifier that is
derived from the venom of the vehicle
and of course it's important to realize
that the venom is publicly readable and
it's basically just readable from the
windshield of the car
so what we can do is we can remove this
secure element from the bcm
because the
secure element is actually the the
component that stores the vin number
and then we emulate the vin or the
secure element better using this usb to
serial converter and we basically take
this bcm into believing that it belongs
to a different phenom
so now if we go back to a plan of attack
we can first use our modified bcm
to force our target keyfob to wake up
we then connect to the keyfob and push
we can now request a valid unlock token
from the secure element over bluetooth
low energy
and we can then use this rolling code to
unlock the car
so now we have a fully remote attack
that allows us to get inside of the car
but of course it's more fun if we can
also drive over the car
and to see how we can achieve that we
looked at how tesla pass a new key fob
to the car
and in practice if you go to the service
center they do this using
the tesla toolbox
which is basically a software tool
that's used for servicing model s and
model x vehicles
the tool is not publicly available
but as with many other
items they are available on the internet
and tesla even unintentionally released
a version of this tool recently
basically if you registered for a
chinese service account you could
download the software for free
now all of the interesting components of
this tool are actually stored encrypted
on disk
but as you can imagine the tool itself
has to decrypt these modules before it
can use them
i'm not going to go into the details of
how you decrypt these modules because
other people have already done this
before me
and i'm also not the first to use the
toolbox software for security research
so in a normal scenario we have a
service technician with a laptop that's
running the tesla toolbox software
and as their service technician we
assume that they have valid toolbox
credentials which also allows the
software to communicate with a backend
hardware security module that is hosted
by tesla
then there is a usb to con interface
that connects to the diagnostic
connector inside of the vehicle
and that basically allows the toolbox
software to send apdu commands to the
secure element in the body control
module
on the other side we have a usb to
bluetooth adapter that allows the
toolbox software to send apdu commands
to the secure element in the keyfob
now to figure out how we can send
commands to the secure element in the
body control module
we actually enumerated
uds routines basically
i don't have time to go into all of the
details of this
but the idea is
relatively straightforward so we can
look at the specifications of uds and
then
try to find ways in which we can
enumerate existing routines
so that's step one and then step two is
to enumerate the option record length so
this is basically additional data that
you can provide to a routine start
method
and then we start the routine with
optional regit data
so we assume here basically that to send
an apu command you would have to start a
routine and provide extra input data to
the routine
so then basically what we did here is we
have the the ecu on a bench
and we have the logic analyzer connected
to the secure element interface
then to this usb to con adapter we send
these
routine start commands and then we look
in the data of the secure of the logic
analyzer if our data sent over can
actually
received at the input of the secure
element
and if that's the case then we know
which routine can be used to communicate
with the secure elements
then to
actually reverse engineer the
the pairing protocol
between the key fob and the car um we
used not only the toolbox software the
toolbox software allowed us to basically
understand the message format or the
the type of data exchanged between the
two secure elements
but it didn't allow us to reverse
engineer what the secure element itself
was doing
and to do that we basically interacted
with two secure elements then made a
guess for what the secure element was
doing and verified it
and in this way we were able to reverse
engineer the entire bearing protocol
which can be divided into two parts so
we first have a provisioning step
which is basically a set of steps that
every brand new key fob would go to
as you can see in this protocol only the
backend hsm the toolbox
and the keyboard and the key fob are
involved
so the car is not yet involved during
these steps
now every keyfob can store 5 rsa
keypairs
and in this case slot 0 and slot 1 are
reserved for tesla specific certificates
and public keys
then basically the keyfob will generate
rsa keypays for the three remaining
slots
and now the idea is that these public
keys will be sent to the backend hsm
the hsm will generate certificates for
these public keys and these certificates
are then stored back into the secure
element of the key fob
so presumably here the idea is that
once we pair this key fob to the car
that the car would be able to verify
these certificates and to verify that
it's pairing to a legitimate key fob
however if we then look at the actual
pairing protocol
where the car is now involved with the
toolbox and the key fob
then we can see that these certificates
are never being used so the key fob is
never sending the certificates to the
secure element
and this basically allows us to skip all
of these provisioning steps and make a
fake
tesla keyfob
i'm not going to go into all of the
details of the pairing protocol itself
but you can always look at the diagram
later in the slides
so i said that we would use a modified
keyfob to do this and this is what our
modified keyfob looks like
so basically we have to replace the
standard secure elements so that we can
skip all of these provisioning steps
so we could either find try to find a
matching component
with a matching footprint and then
program that to do all of these actions
but instead we replace the secure
element using a usb to uart converter
and we can then basically implement all
of the secure element functionality and
python
so i chose to use the cp-2102
um usb to seal converter because it
allows to set an arbitrary ball trade
and it has some extra gpi opens which
are useful in this case
so with that we have a complete plan of
attack
we again use a modified bcm to wake up
the target keyfob this can be done
wirelessly
then we connect to the keyfob and push
our malicious firmware again wirelessly
and this malicious firmware allows us to
remove the block list on the apdu
interface
we can now connect to the keyfob and
request a valid unlock token from the
secure element
we use that
token to unlock the car and gain
physical access to the interior
we can then connect our tool to the
diagnostic connector inside of the
vehicle and pair our modified key fob to
the car and now we can use that key fob
to drive off
we actually built a tool that allows us
to carry out this full attack
and it's battery powered and fits in a
backpack
so basically we have a lipo battery here
that powers this raspberry pi
raspberry pi is basically the brains of
the operation and controls all of the
other components
raspberry pi has a can shield on top of
it that has two interfaces one interface
is connected to the bcm on the back of
our tool
and then the second interface will be
connected to the diagnostic connector
inside of the vehicle
here you can again see the modified
keyfob which is being controlled
from a python script that's running on
the raspberry pi
on the back side of our tool we have the
modified body control module
where again we have modified or he moved
to secure helmets and replaced it with a
usb to sail converter and in this way we
can make this body control module
believe that it belongs to a different
car
now after identifying these issues we
also reported the issues to tesla
so we reported the issues in august of
2020 they released a patch in november
of 2020 in which they fixed the
signature check issue in the firmware
update of the keyfob and they are water
this with a 5 000 bounty
if you want to read more about this
there's a wired article that has some
nice information in it
and the full scientific paper will also
be published in a few weeks
now to end this presentation i want to
show you a demonstration video of how we
would actually conduct this attack in
practice
so in this scenario we have someone
parking their car in front of our
university building and maybe they're
going to charge it and then go for a
walk or have a buy to eat somewhere
and the idea here now is that we can
using our tool
approach the parked car and we can read
the vin number from the windshield we
enter this fin
the number in our python tool that then
basically
allows us to emulate
the dcm so we now have a bcm
that believes it belongs to that same
car
we can then use that bcm
to wake up the key fob in the owner's
pocket
and once it starts advertising as a
connectable ble peripheral
we connect to it and we start pushing
our malicious firmware the firmware
update itself is performed over
bluetooth energy and can just be
performed over a longer range
once the device has been updated we can
connect to it and request some valid
one-time one-time valid unlock commands
as these are holding codes we also have
to use them in the same way or in the
same order as we receive them
so with these unlock commands we can
then walk back to the car
and send them to the car to unlock the
doors
so we unlock the doors and then of
course this is a model x so we also have
to open the falcon wing doors
so in doing so we've now gained physical
access to the interior of the vehicle
but with these one-time valid unlock
tokens we wouldn't be able to drive off
so to drive off we are now going to pair
our modified key fob to the car
so we plug in our tool to the diagnostic
connector
which is located underneath the center
display in the car
then we can start the pairing process
from uh from our phone basically and
within a few seconds our malicious key
fob is now back to the car
the car will send us a challenge
and our key fob will compute the valid
response to then start the vehicle
and of course once that's done we can
simply drive off with the car
as we now have a key fob that's paired
to the car we would also be able to
restart the car as many times as we want
so it's not like a relay attack
now to conclude this presentation i have
some
basically yearly reminders
over the air updates can be both a
blessing and a curse
so in this case it's the functionality
basically that allowed us to compromise
the key fob but it's also the
functionality that allowed tesla to fix
the
issue a secure element
does not guarantee a secure system and
it's important to remember here that
usually the attacker will try to bypass
the cryptography and not penetrate it
sheldon cooper once said that everything
is better with bluetooth but i think
it's important to remember that
everything has more attack surface with
bluetooth
and then finally you have to remember
that all embedded devices live in a
hostile environment so if you're going
to rely on a general purpose
microcontroller for security critical
operations you're likely going to have
bad time
so with that i want to end this
presentation
you can watch the video again on this
youtube link and you can always contact
me if you have questions the full paper
will soon be released online